if a cryptocurrency like bitcoin were to  become a commonly accepted medium of  exchange a global decentralized monetary  system that no third party can stop or  control  would the us government attempt to make  it illegal and to prosecute the  developers who contribute to its code  base  is software protected by the first  amendment  tornado cache is a tool and tools are  neutral just like bitcoin encryption  guns even telephones terrorists and  dictators can use them as can human  rights activists and dissidents the  government should target the criminals  and authoritarians who threaten human  freedom not the programmers and  cryptographers who build new  technologies that can better secure  human freedom  [Music]